You asked him why he taken the job knowing and this is a quote
that you will never be welcome here.
>> There is no
without journalism.
>> This attack on CBS is an attack on American democracy
by a billionaire who doesn't give a about your country or democracy
itself.
>> We all know the general structure here for the Scott
Pelley stuff, right? You all know the general structure that
Scott Pelley was the host of 60 Minutes and he was like the face
of 60 Minutes at this point, okay?
And he was fired recently. And I think basically the thing is
firing reason was like kind of trumped up. He was speaking out
about what he thought was journalistic malpractice on behalf
of CBS broadly.
He was speaking up against what he thought was journalistic malpractice
at CBS broadly and they fired him. This follows like multiple
mass layoffs, multiple
like questionable decisions, people complaining, people going
to the media about both 60 Minutes and CBS broadly and it all
sort of ties back to Barry Weiss trying to help the Trump administration.
This has been the obvious pattern that everybody's pointed out
for the past I want to say well, since Barry Weiss was put on
as the I guess the head of CBS since they bought the Free Press
and made her the head of CBS. Okay? This has been a problem the
whole time.
Scott Pelley just sat down for an hour-long interview.
Maybe before we do the interview, I can go through some of the
timeline here,
Give me one second. >> to my boss, Tanya Simon.
>> Two of the things in the email include
can we make the protesters look more
Now, I'm paraphrasing.
I don't have the quote, but that's what was communicated to me.
And the other thing was Renee Good's car, you need to describe
her as driving toward the officer. This uh is not what you see
on the video. >> Dude, that's crazy that they're giving
you talking like you're a journalist and they're saying, "No,
no, no, don't come to your own conclusions. Present it this
I was like, uh no. How about how about I'm going to say what
I see? >> you see
uh the officer standing slightly
off the front of the car. And you clearly see Ms. Good's wheels
turned completely as far as they will go away from the officer.
But he shoots her in the head, kills her, and says something
about her in that moment that I can't repeat uh in polite company.
So,
we have gone out of our way in our plan from the very beginning
to show the protesters for the
that they had.
We'd already scrubbed the video archives looking for those scenes.
But it somehow wasn't enough for Ms.
The video showed that the officer wasn't standing in front of
the car and she wasn't driving toward him, but that's what the
president said about that. And that's the way she wanted it described.
>> The real question here is
and I I hate to say it so bluntly, it's probably about how Israel-centric
you want to get with this analysis. Bari Weiss is an infamous
like is an infamous Zionist. She has been a pro-Zionist voice
in media for a long time. She's been trying to infiltrate more
like more heterodox spaces. She's He's trying to infiltrate like
a lot of different, you know, high-level thinking spaces and
to push pro-Zionist talking points for a very, very, very long
time.
so the way you look at this is
what is the I guess what's the hierarchy going on here? Is this
is this
Larry Ellison telling Bari Weiss what to do because
because he wants to support the Trump regime because they're
supporting Israel? Or is it like what what's the
Or is it that
is it because of Israel or is it because, you know, Larry Ellison
wants his business deals to go through, his mergers to go through
that his son's organizing and that's why they want the Trump
regime on their side? It's both for sure. It's both at the same
time, but what are
the major reasons for this happening? I Well, I know that I know
Ellison is a major I know that he's the biggest private donor
ever to the IDF. I know what Larry Ellison's all about. I'm saying
that he also wants his business deals to go through. And then
those business deals themselves, is he building a media monopoly
for himself because he thinks it's profitable or is he building
a media monopoly in order to astroturf support for Israel?
That's and I know I Well, I'm trying to I understand that you
guys all want to go Israel, Israel, Israel. I'm trying to give
you the basis to make that argument
sounding without people going, "Well, why do you think that?"
And then you go, "Uh well, Larry Ellison IDF." I'm trying to
give you all of the context here, okay? That's what I'm trying
to do. I'm trying to help you. So, this started as far as I remember
with the Psychot stuff. The Psychot stuff It started with the
Free Press being acquired by
CBS, okay? Bari Weiss becoming the head of CBS.
This is for 60 Minutes. Bill Owens, executive producer of 60
Minutes, resigns. This is 1 year ago. This is April 2025. Now,
I think this is technically before the merger, but this is in
the lead-up to the merger where essentially I think the the head
of CBS
is basically putting pressure on this guy to start changing coverage,
to start getting coverage more aligned with the Trump camp with
the Trump administration, okay? May 2025, more employees leaving
and being fired. 12 CBS News figures who resigned or lost jobs
under the new regime and what they've said. So, this was in,
I believe, May of 2025 is when Wendy McMahon, the president CEO,
steps down. October 25, 25, Josh Dickerson
Who is Josh? One of these guys is it. >> Finally, tonight,
this is our last night anchoring the CBS Evening News. And we
want to leave you with some farewell thoughts tonight. >> Massive
amounts of turnover is the general idea here, okay?
Even in 2025.
May 2026, so May 2026 of this year Anderson Cooper bids farewell
to CBS 3 weeks ago, okay? Shortly before Scott Pelley is fired.
Now, I think Anderson Cooper was the guy who would go and do
the interviews for them, right? He would do a lot of the interviews.
He would do a lot of like he would do travel for them, I believe.
this is another canary for everybody,
And then what was December of 2025, I think is when the Psychot
story gets paused, the story that looks bad for Trump. There
are just exa- there's example after example after example of
all of this conduct that makes things look worse and worse and
worse. This is the Psychot segment that got delayed,
This is in what, February 2026?
Bari Weiss sends a memo to everybody explaining why she delayed
the Psychot piece, right? We don't have her memo here, but she
sent a big memo basically trying to say we're we're trying to
be more even-handed here. We're We think that like there's been
bias in news and we're trying to be more even-handed. Basically,
suggesting that all of these people are biased who are in her
And then
shortly before Scott Pelley had his last stand, okay? 60 Minutes
basically didn't they opted not to renew the contracts of a bunch
of their staff. So, basically they had contracts with a bunch
of their staff, their correspondents and stuff, and they decided
to let those people go over, I think, the Cycode stuff. So, over
people complaining over the Cycode stuff, they just declined
to renew their contracts, okay? Then, June 2nd is when Scott
Pelley is ousted, and I think we're going to get all the context
we need from the Scott Pelley interview on Scott Pelley's like
ouster from 60 Minutes, all right? So, without further ado, let's
get into it. Scott Pelley on his firing and the massacre at 60
Minutes. >> There was a thumb on the scale
for the president's
version of events that I felt was a level of political influence
that I had never seen in 37 years at CBS News.
>> I'm Lulu Garcia-Navarro, and this is the interview.
It's hard to overstate the impact of 60 Minutes on journalism.
From Mike Wallace and Ed Bradley
>> water shells going on >> to Lesley Stahl
Anderson Cooper, and until this past week, Scott Pelley. >> We
don't torture people. >> Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, we don't
torture
>> We do not I don't talk about techniques >> Pelley
was fired after an explosive series of events and much turmoil
at CBS, including a controversial financial settlement with President
Trump, the sale of the network to David Ellison, and the appointment
of Barry Weiss to lead CBS News. >> She was putting a thumb
on the scale on behalf of the administration. >> Pelley,
along with a number of other 60 Minutes correspondents who were
fired, have now accused Weiss of editorial interference and bias,
charges that CBS and Weiss deny. This is Scott Pelley's first
sit-down interview since he was fired. I want to actually start
by just
asking you how you're feeling in this moment before we start
how you got here.
>> Well, if we want to talk about it at an emotional level,
the best thing that I can imagine in terms of describing it is
that it's it's like your spouse was murdered.
Oh, that hits hard, actually. Jesus
But I I get it. Like, for Scott Pelley, he's been here for like
decades, right?
He's He's been there for decades. He's built like this this show
has been his life for a very long time.
And so, how could he possibly feel any other way? It's like something
he's put his blood, sweat, and tears into, like building a marriage,
right? Literally married to his job. Yeah, like he's put all
of this work into it. I do get how he could think that. Like,
yeah, no, I this has been my life and it's being taken away.
>> Even worse than it being taken away, cuz maybe you could
deal with it being taken
But it's not just being taken away. It's being like
It's being defiled, okay? It's like It's not even like having
your spouse be murdered. It's like watching your spouse be defiled
by some of the most disgusting individuals on planet Earth, >> A
few days before your firing, several high-profile 60 Minutes
correspondents and leaders were
Was that the sort of change you were
>> I No one saw the Black Thursday massacre
This is our entire senior staff.
People beloved. Tanya Simon, our executive producer, she's the
boss.
And this was her triumph. She's the first
woman ever to be executive producer of 60 Minutes. And she concluded
this season
with a growth in our audience of 9%,
which is unheard of in broadcast
>> Oh, this is Oh, this does a really good job of painting
out the bias. Oh, I I wonder how smart they're going to be about
this. Cuz it's like, okay, we're we're doing something great
here. We're like able to change this." I'm guessing Bari Weiss
will say, "No, no, no, it's because we're being less biased.
We're being less like leftist biased."
Okay. No, maybe not. >> And [clears throat] to growth in
our online presence of 190%
last season, we had 2.5
That's a third of humanity.
we're riding high.
And 1/3 of our correspondents
have been fired. And at the same moment that that happens,
we are informed of our new executive
His name is Nick Bilton.
I'm sure he must
>> Nick. Nick Bilton, eh?
>> Explain to me exactly how you felt. >> Um shock,
dismay,
uh impossible to believe,
>> searching desperately for an
>> knowing that an explanation would be forthcoming and
then not seeing that.
No executive at CBS News, uh our editor-in-chief, Bari Weiss,
coming over to 60 Minutes to talk with us, to sit with us. That's
a family
at 60 Minutes.
>> Bari Weiss. Oh my hate Bari Weiss. [__]
that [__]
>> Sorry. Has to be said. Has to be Has to be said sometimes,
okay? >> We dine together. >> to throw it out there
sometimes. >> literal combat together. And we got through
the weekend, and I learned that uh Nick Bilton was going to speak
to the 60 Minutes staff on that next Monday
>> At that meeting, you
spoke up very forcefully. Um you asked
why he'd taken the job knowing, and this is a quote, that you
will never be welcome here. Why did you decide to have that >> Why
did you take this job knowing that we all hate you? Why did you
take this job knowing that you'll never be welcome here? You're
a total sham. You're a total schmuck. You're just a
flunky. Why did you take the job? You're a total loser. Everybody's
going to hate you. You think we're the only ones who are going
to hate you? No, the American public will know your name. They'll
know you were a part of this They will hate >> that first
interaction with your new boss in public and not behind closed
>> It wasn't in public.
It was behind closed doors.
>> I was with my family
in a closed room.
None of this was meant to be public.
>> But Lulu, imagine I'm walking into this
with these people who have devoted their lives to 60 Minutes.
>> They have not received any kind of
They are waiting for Barry Weiss to walk in the room
in the hope that she's going to explain why this tragedy has
occurred
and why it was so necessary.
And
I'm waiting to
see who comes in and it's uh Nick Bilton and one of um Barry's
deputies, no Barry.
People are a little shocked by this. As we're standing in there,
Nick makes his way to the front of the room
and
does something absolutely jaw-dropping to me. >> Dude,
there's no way he comes in and goes, "We had to cut some of the
fat. We had to cut some of the dead weight, some of those losers
who were here before. Yeah, we had to get them out of here, guys."
There's no way he comes and denigrates the people who came before
him, right? Like not Dude, there's no way they hired man to lead
this this unit to be executive producer here. There's no way
he can't he he can't feel the seething coming from all these
people, how much they hate him. And he gets There's no way, right?
I realize I've just done a whole bunch of like lead-up to this
and now it might not even be that, but there's just no way he
could possibly
>> He pulls out his phone
and begins reading a statement
off his
in a room full of 50 heartbroken people.
>> Basically insensitive.
>> The Still an man, still an >> tone deafness of
that
you could hear the groan in the room when that happened. And
they'd put out a big spread of bagels like we were all going
to feel better. And all >> A big spread of what? A big
spread of
No.
There's >> Also, if I can give you a little bit of
>> What had happened a couple of days before the meeting
was so critical.
Nick Bilton wrote an email to the staff
sort of introducing himself.
it was
so insulting
to the staff and so insulting
uh to the history of 60 Minutes. Um he told us in that email
that um it wasn't 1968 anymore.
>> And he helpfully noted that gasoline doesn't cost 32
cents anymore.
>> And suggested that we had all been frozen in amber in
1968 when the program first went on the air and that nothing
had improved. And he said in his email that it was  strange
that 60 Minutes is only on the air at 7:00 Eastern time on Sunday
once a week.
>> When we've been on the air
globally online
for
well over a decade,
it betrayed the fact
Nick Bilton didn't know anything about us. Didn't know anything
about our culture.
And yet was being imposed on us as our new executive producer,
our new leader.
So, people read that memo.
It's very concerning.
It's heartbreaking.
It's hard to compare this to anything other than something that
actually could happen to your family.
It's a very
and empathetic organization.
And we were met with cold,
to what anyone thought. >> Why did you feel that you were
the person that needed to
get the answers to the questions that you had and everyone had
at that meeting? Why did you feel compelled to speak up? >> It
was fate.
You know, first of all, our entire senior staff had been wiped
out. They're not there.
I looked around the room. I'm the only correspondent there, which
surprised me very much. I learned that my colleagues were out
shooting stories as they should be in the month of June.
But I'm the only correspondent there, which surprised me. And
I looked around at my friends and colleagues in the room and
realized I was the senior person.
I could do it.
None of them could be asked
to take that risk.
So, when I saw Nick Bilton's email and then saw him reading
to my broken-hearted people off his
um I felt >> Like, how do you give yourself away as a total
drone?
Right? In in any more effective way than to go, "Well, I'm not
going to speak about anything I think. I'm not going to speak
up from from the heart. I'm not going to speak to these people
directly. I'm just going to read something that someone else
wrote. I'm just going to read something else, you know, real
quick. Bro. >> You then do have a meeting with CBS leadership
after this very contentious
um, interaction.
Can you tell me about that meeting and and if you were at that
going in expecting to be fired? >> Oh, gosh. Furthest thing
from my mind. It hadn't occurred to me. The president of CBS
News, uh, Tom Sboro sky sent me a note and said, "Can you come
by and talk to us?" I said, "Absolutely." I scheduled about an
hour on my calendar for the meeting. I didn't know who was going
to be there, uh, in the meeting. So, I walk in the door
and I see Barry Weiss is sitting in there and I think, "This
is terrific of
She she's come to this meeting and and now I'm going to be able
to ask her these questions. She's going to be able to explain
what happened." >> But, it really didn't occur to you that
you could be fired after so many of your colleagues had been
let go after you >> I thought he made some comments that
basically they decided they were going to let him go. But, I
think they were they were comments in private. >> this
you know, >> I also think he probably thinks, and I hope
he says it, like, "I'm Scott Pelley. You going to fire me? I'm
like the face of this entire program. You going to fire the guy
who's the face of the entire program? How? Why?
Cuz he's a dick. Cuz he's like a dick. Cuz you were dicks. No
shot. >> a very contentious
interaction with your new boss. >> You know some reporter
I turned out to be. Uh, I just didn't connect the dots. I mean,
was this meeting contentious? Yes, but
60 Minutes is known for two things. A ticking stopwatch and hard
questions. And we ask ourselves those hard questions in the shop
because they sharpen us and make us better.
There was a screening once with Mike Wallace and Mike and the
executive producer and founder of 60 Minutes Don Hewitt got into
a big argument about a
>> Wallace jumps up in the middle of the
Throws his script up in the air and yells at Don, "Well, then
you write the effing thing." One of those pieces of paper comes
down and slices an associate producer across the face. He's bleeding
now. He's got a paper cut on his face. >> What the >> That
was about a story. The meeting that I was in was about
>> I do think that sounds almost unbelievable, but I want
to say that that shit's happened. I feel like I've seen that
happen.
Not Not quite that, but people like like throwing paper and it
ends up like you would Never on someone's face. I've seen somebody
get a paper cut like that. Not very deep, not very broad. But
just basically like someone throwing paper in somebody else's
face and it basically one of them just sort of like bends in
a way it just does this slight little paper cut.
>> whether 60 Minutes was going to even survive or not.
>> So you walk in and what was the energy of the room?
dismissive. Before I could take my seat, Tom Sobolowski said,
"This is a firing
>> I was confused. I wasn't sure who he was talking about
in the room.
>> Okay. Okay. Come on. >> But it became plain very
quickly that they were talking about me and they were unhappy
about the meeting that had occurred. A meeting that had ended
in thunderous applause
uh for me. If I may say so. Because somebody had stood up for
the broadcast.
So, I sit down like, okay, well, let's talk about it.
Tom accuses me of physically
Nick Bilton. This is a lie.
I didn't come within 10 ft of Nick >> Dude, that's >> Oh,
no. Oh, no.
>> I hate to say it, but I am going to say it. I actually
don't hate to say it anymore. Straight-up Israeli tactics. Straight-up
Israeli tactics, okay? I'm sorry, but that's what that is right
there. Actually, you physically assaulted this man.
I was not within 10 ft of him. Physically assaulted. >> In
my life,
I have never put my hands on anyone
in anger.
Not one time.
And when he was caught in that lie,
he said, well, okay, I take that back.
And I said, great.
>> Conversation proceeded a little bit. I
>> Dude, I
I think Man, I wish he would have walked out the second they
said that. That's slander. I'm leaving. You You just You've obviously
given away your attempt to fire me with this. I'm going to go
now. I'm going to hire a lawyer, and we're going to come back
and we're going to talk about this with a lawyer in the room.
Right? You just made something up. You said this is a firing
offense, and then you made something up. I'm going to get a lawyer
to come and sit in this conversation before we have it again.
>> Turned to Barry Weiss who was sitting to my left, and
I said, but let's, you know, let's talk about the firings. Why
were the firings necessary?
I'm not answering that question.
Well, how did Tanya Simon not lead the broadcast brilliantly?
Okay. Sherrod Alford.
Cecilia Vega. I mean
what possible reason could there be to take them off the air?
I'm not answering that question.
So now I'm detecting a pattern that's going to go nowhere. She
is still going to stonewall about why she took all these people
out. So
I'm thinking that the meeting's going to carry on. We're going
to have a long conversation. I'm going to hear from them about
what they think.
They're going to hear from me about what I think.
>> Oh, you thought they were honest.
Now I'm starting to feel a little bit less empathy for Scott
Pelley, okay? At what point, at anywhere along this entire set
of circumstances,
did you go, "Well, now I'm sure Barry Weiss is going to be honest."
Yeah, she had to just lie a whole bunch. She had to just You
know, she had to pressure us to cover things differently a whole
bunch. She had to lie constantly throughout her entire career.
And now, finally, she's going to be honest right now.
Oh, wait. No, you're Wait, you're telling me she's just going
to be a totally dishonest hack again? No. What?
No. No way. >> Um the temperature in the room is low, but
it's very hostile from their side.
I'm speaking about the way I'm speaking to you now. Very quickly
after the meeting began,
Tom Sobolowski said, "This conversation is over."
I was stunned. I didn't have a 60 minute stopwatch in that room.
I don't know how long it lasted, really, but I think it was about
10 minutes. So they tell me that is to say, Tom Sobolowski tells
me as I'm walking through the door, "You'll have our answer in
a few minutes." I went over to my office and much to my
all of my guys on my team were still
They wanted to know what happened in the meeting. What was that
all about? Did they explain why our people were fired.
And um I sat down in my office. It has a big plate glass window
that looks out on the newsroom and there were a whole bunch of
people standing out there, but I didn't think anything of it.
I'm waiting to find out what my fate is. I explained to my team,
I think I just got fired, but they haven't told me that. And
then I look up and all those people are still out there and the
staff members and I don't think anything of And then it hits
me.
And this is a vigil.
>> An hour goes by, 2 hours go by, 3 hours go by,
4 hours go by and I go back outside and said, I'm leaving. You
been standing out there for 4 hours. I said, I'm leaving. You
guys have got to go home to your families right now. I doubt
they're going to tell me tonight.
So, I packed up and left just so those people would go home.
And not long after that the email came through and said that
I'd been fired. >> Just to understand your
position in this, you would have been open to a path forward.
You wanted to remain at 60 Minutes.
A path forward to me was a obvious
conclusion for what this meeting was going to be about. That's
exactly what I
And
I expected them to say, look, this is why we had to fire everybody.
I mean, you your questions Scott are valid and here's here's
why we did what we did. So, stay at 60 Minutes? Absolutely.
I it didn't occur to me that this could >> But Scott,
in a meeting you accused
Barry Weiss, the head of the network,
wanting to murder the show, of coming
into 60 Minutes with the agenda to
the institution.
And you did not think that that was going to have repercussions
that could lead to your firing?
>> Just be honest. Be honest, Scott.
Say, "I'm
that ninja. Just I'm that ninja. You can't I'm literally the
face. What are they going to do? They're going to fire the face?
I'm like the reason this program works right now."
That's That's all he needs to say cuz I do believe that's what
he thinks. He's not going to say it cuz it's cocky to say it,
but that's quite literally what he thinks.
Like I You literally can't fire me. What are you going to That's
the last shred of credibility your show has.
used to be able to have conversations like that at CBS News.
the the difference today is that the people running CBS News
will not be
>> You have now accused
Weiss of injecting
and I'm quoting here falsehoods and
Uh this was in your parting statement into at least one of your
politically sensitive stories.
Can you tell me the nature of that um
complaint? What did she specifically ask for? What story are
you talking about? >> As I recall, that's February.
And my team and I are doing a story about the protests in Minneapolis
against the ICE crackdown there.
We've interviewed Senator Rand Paul,
because
he's going to hold hearings into this. And the fact that a Republican
was going to do that was quite newsworthy. So, we interviewed
Senator Paul,
and then built out a story about what had happened. Uh the of
Renee Good, the of Alex Preddy, the protests.
I felt it was very important
to identify that the protesters themselves
were being very aggressive.
And that they were half of the these
And so I instructed my producers
to find images over the past few weeks of these protests in which
we see the protesters acting aggressively.
Uh we found a picture of a protester chest bumping an officer.
We found a picture of an officer being hit in the head with a
snowball.
Uh we
culled together a lot of video of protesters screaming in the
faces of officers because we were going to talk about the of
pretty and the of good and it seemed to me important to tell
the audience about the entire context.
In fact, I remember writing a line in the story
that said that the protesters
were pushing the boundaries of what it means to peacefully assemble
taking the language from the first amendment.
And I thought we'd done a really good job with this. We also
included a picture of Alex Pretty before he was killed. Uh k-
>> So like what you should notice here is already I feel
like he is he's leaning in he's like a centrist, right? He's
not trying to tell one story or the other. He's saying hey like
the protesters were becoming aggressive. They the cops were probably
feeling uneasy. He's not even trying to approach it from anything
that could be conceived as a left-wing biased place, right? Not
even remotely. You couldn't possibly argue this with his approach.
I think it's important framing for whatever comes next in the
conversation. >> kicking out a tail light on a police car
and made a point of saying this is Alex Pretty and this is what
he did. So the story goes through screenings.
Uh it's very well received. There are notes, as always, uh, and
we do rewrites, as always. Um, but this is on a very
tight deadline. It's Sunday.
We're going on the air that night. And in the case of stories
that are, as we say, crashing,
meaning right against the deadline, our deadline on Sunday is
So, we work on all of these things. We get the piece, uh, approved
by everyone.
And about 4 hours after our deadline, Bari Weiss sends an email
to my boss, Tanya Simon.
Two of the things in the email include,
"Can we make the protesters look more
Now, I'm paraphrasing.
I don't have the quote, but that's what was communicated to me.
And the other thing was, "Rene Good's car, you need to describe
her as driving toward the officer." This, uh, is not what you
see on the >> Now, can I ask,
I want to say that I remember Bari Weiss herself being in an
interview and saying this. Am I crazy or did Bari Weiss go on
somewhere, something, somewhere, and say essentially this? I
thought she echoed the terrorist remarks. I thought she echoed
the driving directly at the officer remarks.
Am I Am I hallucinating this? >> On the video, you see,
uh, the officer standing slightly
off the front of the car. >> And you clearly see Ms. Good's
wheels turned completely as far as they will go, away from the
officer. But, he shoots her, uh, in the head, kills her. And
says something about her in that moment that I can't repeat in
polite company. So,
we have gone out of our way in our plan from the very beginning
to show the protesters for the
that they had.
We had already scrubbed the video archives looking for those
scenes.
But it [snorts] somehow wasn't enough for Ms. Weiss. The video
showed that the officer wasn't standing in front of the car and
she wasn't driving toward him, but that's what the president
said about that and that's the way she wanted it to
>> Is January 14th, 2026. The same Barry Weiss who killed
the six a 60 minute segment critical to the Trump administration
because she had concerns about airing it without a sufficient
response from the administration published a piece claiming the
agent who killed Renee Good suffered internal bleeding without
receiving a shred of evidence from the administration to support
that claim.
This is This is what I'm talking about right here. This is like
essentially from January. I'm looking for Did she just allow
it to be published or was it
Was it her words specifically?
Yes, it's on the injuries sustained by the officer. >> archives
looking for those scenes.
But it somehow wasn't enough for Ms. Weiss. The video showed
that the officer wasn't standing in front of the car and she
wasn't driving toward him, but that's what the president said
about that and that's the way she wanted it >> To be clear,
there were lots of videos that showed different moments of that
>> And there was a big many analyses subsequently about
what exactly through those various videos had actually >> Including
an excellent one by the New York Times. The video [snorts] that
I showed in our
uh clearly showed the officer's feet.
So, if he's standing in front of the car, you can't see his feet.
And it very clearly showed that the wheels were turned away from
him what appeared to be the maximum
>> turn until the wheel had stopped. >> So, you get
suggestions
um
feedback from the sort of editorial chief of CBS News.
What did you do? I mean, did you do as she asked?
>> I asked my producer >> That happened to him 6
months before when he got dragged. She's just a No, the administration
was saying he suffered internal bleeding from this
The administration said that and they they uncritically re-reported
it.
I told you to find violent video of the protesters so we could
represent that accurately. Now, I want you to go back and look
again. Did we leave anything out that's important?
What What Did we make a mistake here?
I don't think so, but go back and look.
And then I sat down with a video editor and I went over the video
of the Renee good over and over and over again, stop motion,
slow motion, etc.
realized that the event was not as the president said and not
the way Barry Weiss remembered it. And so, um it's late. Our
deadline was noon.
It's now almost 5:00.
That's dangerous as hell.
And so, I decided that I wouldn't do those things.
I wasn't going to get in a debate about it. I wasn't going to
call Barry Weiss about it. I was just going to refuse to make
those changes.
>> Did you change any language in the
broadcast, anything? >> Not that I recall
based on her notes,
uh as you probably are aware, uh when you're doing a story, especially
on deadline, a lot of things happen. There's a lot of input,
and you're just scrambling to save everybody's skin because you're
going to have a crash.
>> I think he's basically saying like not that I remember,
but it could have like if I took one of her suggestions without
realizing it, reiterated on on video or on TV, I it wasn't because
I intended to, it's just because it happened. >> I want
to ask you point-blank, what did you think was going on with
Bari Weiss? Why did you think she was asking for these things?
>> It's funny cuz he's a journalist. It's
it to some extent, I think a journalist will always be guarded
with this because they realize that their opinion, even if they
say it's just their personal opinion, doesn't reflect anything
else. I do think
he will
have some concern about sharing it, right? Like it it's just
his voice saying things grants it weight, so he's going to hem
and haw a little bit. I don't think he's going to get into the
Israel thing. I think he's going to get into the protecting the
Trump administration thing. I don't I don't think that he's going
to engage on that deeper level at all. >> The impression
that I had at the moment was that
she was
Let me try uh guys are going to need to be a little bit careful
here because I don't want to be hyperbolic. My impression
at the time was that she was putting a thumb on the scale on
behalf of the administration, just constantly
looking out for
the views of the president.
Uh we're reporting those views. There's nothing wrong with reporting
those views, but it was it was never enough.
Always needed more from the president from the administration.
That sort of thing. The the balance was off.
We've been working
for balance for decades and for the first time in my career the
balance was off. >> President Trump reacted to your being
fired. >> Did he? >> He went on a podcast and called
you a
>> I'm surprised
that the president of the United States would bother to notice
but okay. Please tell me I'm not aware of this. >> He also
said you were part of this gang of stupid crooked people that
don't care about your country.
stupid I can
I can take that.
Stiff yeah, probably.
don't care about the country?
I've never worn the uniform.
But I've been in combat for this
In Afghanistan
and Iraq.
Kuwait [snorts]
been shot at.
Spent nights in foxholes
filling up with water in the desert.
I'm not aware
that the president of the United States has ever done any of
those things for his country.
Please correct me if I'm wrong.
You become a journalist
because you love the First Amendment.
You become a journalist because you love the country.
And while all the other descriptions that the president used
about me might be applicable
not that one.
>> There is no
without journalism.
>> Let's go.
That's why it's under attack.
Exactly what I was saying very like much earlier in the segment.
You need an informed populace. You need people who are willing
to criticize power. Without these things democracy fails. This
attack on CBS is an attack on American democracy by a billionaire
who doesn't give a [__] about your country or democracy
itself.
Okay? That's the only way to look at it. Anybody supporting these
people, write their name down your head, write their name down
on a list. Anyone who's supporting Bari Weiss, the free press,
CBS News, 60 Minutes from this point forward, right? Not the
employees, but I'm telling you the people who are saying, "Oh,
there's nothing wrong here. I don't know how bad this
Keep track. These people are all enemies of democracy. They will
all need to be dealt with in time. So, I'm sounding very ominous.
But dealt with I mean, they will need to be identified correctly
when they do this stupid cope argumentation later in later in
time, okay? They will all say, "Well, I I don't know if it's
really that big a deal, man." Yeah, I don't need to take you
seriously. You're defending Bari Weiss. You're defending CBS.
You're defending all of this [__] We do need to know
who you are. We do need to be able to dismiss your opinion. You
are just a shill. Shut the [__] up.
Yeah, I know. I'm sorry. I sounded ominous there for a second.
I mean, they'll need to be like identified because all they're
going to do
and this is what it is. They're all going to just do this weird
like Oh, you call it sealioning, right? Is it not sealioning?
Where they they'll like ask questions, but they don't have sincere
concern. Well, don't you think that sometimes it's just kind
of like, you know, Bari Weiss might have been an experience and
that was really what all that happened there? No, I don't think
that. No, I I think that. You don't think that. Nobody thinks
that. You're saying it cuz it gives you the ability to get other
people to like basically pause and think for a second, but all
it is is you're trying to cause as much of a time gap as possible
so that this merger is allowed to go through, so that the status
quo becomes acceptable acceptable, and it won't. It cannot become
acceptable.
>> There is no
without journalism. It can't be done, and that is why I am a
journalist.
>> Last few questions.
>> You know on Fox News they're going to just run the parts
where I'm crying and say I'm a lunatic.
>> It's the era [laughter] we live in.
>> It is the era we live in.